Turkey and Europe have just started
trading humans no seriously they're
implementing a deal that's designed to
limit the number of migrants and
refugees smuggling themselves into
Europe sound awful wait till you hear
the details most refugees entering
Europe have done so through Greece
before moving north and seeking asylum
in richer countries now that stopped
since March 20th anyone who's been
smuggled into Greece has been detained
they're locked up until their Asylum
case has been approved or rejected and
if it does get rejected they'll be
shipped off to Turkey for each person
sent back Europe will take one of the
2.7 million Syrian refugees currently in
Turkey not all of them though only
72,000 trading refugees how enlightened
so why would Europe even do this well
the European Union says the number of
people trying to enter its borders is a
crisis well let's put that in context
even if the EU gives asylum to a million
refugees which it hasn't that's still
only 0.02 percent of its population
meanwhile refugees already make up 3.5%
of turkeys population and Lebanon is
hosting 1 million refugees despite a
population of only 4 million that's a
crisis so why is Turkey where many
refugees are already struggling to get
decent work and find a dignified life
agreeing to take on Europe's burden
money Turkey has been asking the
European Union to help it pay for the
refugees that it hosts from this deal
turkey is getting six point eight
billion dollars but that's not all
Turkish citizens will be able to travel
into Europe Schengen zone without a visa
later this year and Turkey's ambition to
join the EU gets a boost negotiations
over that should restart in the next few
months remember these are people fleeing
horrific war and persecution so with
your pain to keep them away can refugees
catch a break